[Musique]
aujourd'hui sont inquiets ont peur pour
leur commerce ont peur pour les
activités c'est la fermeté c'est
l'autorité c'est la sécurité c'est ce à
quoi shampoing le ministre de
l'Intérieur et le ministre la justice et
vous avez compris que la ligne du
gouvernement défendue par la première
ministre est claire le rétablissement
partout sur le territoire de l'autorité
de l'État
[Applaudissements]
je viens aujourd'hui vous annoncer que
la cagnotte qui a été ouverte en soutien
à la famille de notre policier Florian m
va être clôturé ce soir à minuit
je tenais à vous présenter tous mes
remerciements toute ma profonde
gratitude pour cette incroyable élan de
générosité qui a parcouru et traversé
toute la France à bientôt pour de
nouvelles aventures et encore une fois
vive la France et vive vous